[Music]
hi everyone
welcome my name is saba and i head up
all of our global outreach here in mba
admissions which includes our diversity
and inclusion work which is led by will
who hopefully you've all had a chance to
meet at this point in the week
and i am really honored to introduce a
few of our faculty members
and who have a deep bench of expertise
in actually teaching some of the courses
that you might be interested in while
you're a student
focused on building inclusive and
diverse organizations
so um i would love to introduce
fern mundo bond who's our lecturer here
at the gsb she's also an alumna of the
school
and a managing director at the emerson
collective
focused on venture investments there and
also
has been teaching several different
courses focused on diversity equity and
inclusion at the gsb
we're also waiting um just in the next
few moments we'll be joined by professor
adina sterling
who co-teaches some of those classes as
well so fern
welcome thank you so much for being here
i had the honor of actually auditing
your course last spring and it was
absolutely amazing and um i think the
last day of class was right before the
shelter in place order
so lots of fun memories yeah absolutely
i'm i'm delighted to be here thank you
for having me
thank you for joining while we're
waiting
for adina i actually had a few questions
that we wanted to ask both of you and
maybe we can just get started with your
perspective
which is just a little bit about your
background like how you landed at the
gsb where is home for you
and what kind of grounded you in this
work yeah absolutely
i grew up in new york city and
[Music]
i was an entrepreneur starting when i
was a very little kid
i went to brown and when i was at brown
i
applied to business school and this was
a
long time ago before that two plus two
concept um existed
and i i was lucky i got into business
school on the east coast
and stanford and i came out
to to visit stanford and
i realized this was where i was meant to
be um
i've always been entrepreneurial i've
been
starting companies since i was a little
kid
and growing up in new york it you know
is very
um a very corporate environment and
when i got here i realized that i could
pursue what i
i just loved my whole life and
frankly i i never left
lucky for us um thank you for sharing
a little bit about that and i'm also
wondering if you can tell us more about
kind of your expertise in teaching the
courses that you teach here
um kind of what inspired you and are
there any
kind of um concepts or models or
frameworks that have been particularly
influential
and given that you're teaching this
course now which is i think after the
movement for black lives and it's always
been prescient but um just kind of what
inspired your work
and your expertise and research within
kind of the equity realm in particular
yeah i i it's probably helpful to
explain
how this course came about and and how i
even ended up
back at the business school so
after going to business school i started
some companies and and sold them and
and then i ended up what i call coaching
companies helping them
raise money and think about their
strategy and then i ended up
joining starting and joining a venture
fund
and then i started another venture fund
and
and then i ended up at emerson
collective which is really
an amazing place for me to be because
um we care about equity and access it's
it's
you know i can combine all of my
passions
but 10 years ago when i was investing
in whatever companies i was asked to
teach a class called
entrepreneurship from the perspective of
women
and at the time i thought
why me i mean i'm a woman and i'm an
entrepreneur
but i wasn't even in women in management
when i was at the business school
it just i'd always kind of had my head
down
keep moving forward um i i was a poor
kid
i i had a lot of other things that i had
been thinking about and quite frankly i
just
hadn't really noticed um
just or maybe it was my own bias that i
didn't realize the inequities
existed and when i was asked to teach
that class
i went on a listening tour and i
and i talked to about 300 women and then
i expanded that
to people of color in particular black
and latinx
um c-suite executives and i learned
what the challenges are really that
exist
and and since then i've interviewed
about 3 700 people
around the globe on this exact
issue as it relates to to equity
and the more i i learned about it
um the more i wanted to include that in
my teaching
and so that one class is actually turned
into
three different classes
awesome thank you for sharing a little
bit about the background
i think that's actually a great jumping
off point to talk a little bit more
about the course specifically so can you
tell us more
um i think about the the first class
that led to the spin-off i think we can
start it there and if you want to
incorporate the other electives that's
great too
but a little bit about the main learning
goals
the teaching method and um
we'll start there i'll tell you about
the three clashes
and then when adina comes we can really
hone in on equity by design
so the class i'm teaching right now is
entrepreneurship from diverse
perspectives
and in that class for example this
quarter
we have 34 guests and
all of them are from what i refer to as
hugs historically underestimated groups
so they are black founders men and women
latino latinas
people lgbtq people who are disabled in
some way
just to show that that really everyone
has the opportunity
to to do exactly this to be
entrepreneurial
in their lives and in that class you
create a company
in the class i teach in the winter it's
called building the entrepreneurial
mindset
and in that class it's from the
perspective of women
so we hear from all women and we talk
about
the professional and personal sides of
what it takes to actually
be entrepreneurial and then in the
spring
through the demand frankly of our
students
we created the class equity by design
building diverse and inclusive
organizations
and it is it's very very
topical right now but we didn't
we didn't just create the class um i
can't remember is this our fourth year
adina i'm not exactly sure
yeah you know we we we love that we're
doing it
now and you know in this very
interesting time where people are very
focused on
the fact that systemic racism exists but
that is
this isn't this is not a new new issue
um we've we've been experiencing this
for a very long time
and i'm just delighted that the business
school um
includes us as part of the curriculum
thanks for all that background hi
professor sterling welcome adina
we've got about 150 folks on the line
with us
and we're really excited for this whole
week focused on diversity and leadership
this is
an event we've historically held for
about 15 years at the gsb but usually in
person and it's actually been really
exciting to see
just representation of all kinds at this
event
thank you so much for joining
even i think would be great just
introductory for you
as well to let people get to know you a
little bit which is
where is home for you into the gsb and
teaching
some of the courses that you do with
vern in particular
sure so um
a home for me so that's a good question
it's really um i have
families spread out all over
the u.s um and incidentally
now have more siblings in california it
wasn't always this way
but more siblings in california than any
other state which is fun
i'm the oldest of five kids and so
um now have a lot of family in
in los angeles so the particular arc i
i heard the tail end of what fern shared
um
but my research focuses on diversity
equity and inclusion
particularly how social networks
can be hidden um
instantiators of inequality
and destroy unintentionally
diversity efforts and and so networks
and social relationships are
oftentimes taken for granted we all
think about our social connections as
being really
important components of our lives and
they are certainly important
um but oftentimes they
can be full of homophobia which is just
this idea that
you know people who are from similar
backgrounds
congregate together and as a result
what can frequently happen in
organizations
and in startups and in government
and pick your institution is that
through networks um organizations become
social reproducing systems meaning those
that are already there
um and their backgrounds get double down
upon
um and and leads to a lack of diversity
although no one was intending for that
to happen um and so that's what my
my research looks at i've been at
stanford since
um the fall of 2015 and prior to
coming to the gsb i was a professor at
washu
um washington university in st louis in
the strategy group
and um yes teach teach a
elective with fern which is just an
absolute delight
on diversity equity and inclusion and
also teach in our
masters of science and management
program a core course on organizational
design
and i teach phd students
awesome thank you so much for sharing
and i was telling for an earlier when i
had the pleasure of auditing the class
it was just
i think so foundational even for the
work that we think about in mba
admissions and
i think the last class was right before
shelter in place so
timely in so many different ways with
all the
dynamics and change that we're
undergoing in the world now
um i also want to just remind folks i
think given um the background that adina
and fern have shared
and a reminder that if you have any
questions for our
lecturers and professors you can put
those in the q a box and we will be
moving to questions from the audience in
about 15 minutes
um we were about to dive in
i think fern was going to share a little
bit more about
um the learning goals for the equity
by design course in particular um
teaching methods kind of curriculum
design how did the course come about and
when you think about teaching it what is
top of mind for you
you know i can i can dive in on um
how it came about and i think
some of the learning goals and i think
adina can share
our pedagogical approach um
she'd be yeah so
um i mentioned that i taught a class
called um
entrepreneurship from diverse
perspectives and power building the
entrepreneurial mindset
and in both of those classes
people would often ask well how do we
how do we change the culture
or you know if people aren't you know if
we're not hiring certain people
and how do how do we promote the right
people in an organization and it sure
feels like the the playing field isn't
level
however people would describe that and
and i would often say well hold back to
the class where we're talking about
culture
or we'll we'll get to that and
it became crystal clear that people
really wanted to understand
you know how how could they build an
organization
you know rooted in inclusion and
belonging that was truly
equitable um and
i decided to create a class um
and and i'm you know adina is a
professor
in in this area this she has been
studying this her
you know for many years i'm a
practitioner
so what i had experienced around the
country and interviewing people
in working with companies and trying to
what i call build and expand the
ecosystem
had learned about it from that
perspective and of course had read
all of the research i could so we
created what we call
the business school a compressed class
so it was
two weeks six sessions and during that
class we recognized
just the thirst for this knowledge right
how these students could go off and
either create a company where they did
this or
how is someone just joining a company
what can
i do to affect that culture what can i
do to make this a more inclusive
organization
and that was when i i
met with adina i i knew she would be
just
amazing to teach this with me uh many
people at the gsb had suggested i talked
to her
we got together i'll never forget it at
koopa cafe
and i'm not exactly sure this was number
one
on her her agenda on things she wanted
to do
but luckily that was just the beginning
of just the most
incredible journey and our
what we teach and how we teach it we're
always
trying to make it better as a matter of
fact we create something in the class
called the
better practices playbook and because we
don't believe there's a best practice
right we're always learning and always
getting better
even in what we teach and how we teach
it and i'll i'll just kick it over to
adina on
on on what we really dive into yeah
great so i will pick up there
and it is it is such a pleasure
to teach with fern in fact this model
of faculty partnering with practitioners
is really unique at the gsb and we have
people
from schools all over the country and
world say well
how does that work and sometimes
we just don't know what to say because
it works so well you know i think it
comes from
just a lot of mutual respect for one
another
um that you know that we have and i so
value
uh everything that fern um
brings to the table from a
practitioner's standpoint and the way
that
she is in the trenches daily uh with
these topics and and really
diving in um i i will say uh
in terms of the pedagogy and
and what we believe in how we frame the
course
it's it's around this idea um
given that it's an elective that for the
people who are sitting
in our course the people who are
logging in virtually or previously that
were sitting in the class
likely care much more about dei
than perhaps the founder of the company
that they're working
at you know that maybe that the ceo
cares about it not that
people don't care it's just we have a
particularly really bought in
group of students that take the class
and so
a lot of what we do is think about
and just really unpack
why beliefs and diversity equity and
inclusion as as
this ideal and something worth aspiring
to isn't a necessary prerequisite
for change and and that's just this idea
that
you know all of us think so much
about the importance of beliefs and you
know
gosh my my coworker or my peer
has to be all bought in i mean i'm
bought in and so
let's have them be bought in and that
that's the precursor to change
and that's not the approach that we take
there's actually about 40 years of
social psychological research that says
it's not belief that needs to precede
action
that if you put in practices and
behaviors
that is what generates change
in mindsets changes in beliefs
and so we through either two weeks in
the compressed class
or some 10 weeks if it's a quarter long
class
go through design principles
that will change an organization even if
everyone's not bought it
and and so it's things like how do you
make hiring criteria
better that guess what is more equitable
at the same time
and through equity will generate
diversity
and sometimes those are really
you know i think for people in the class
they kind of get it but for a lot of
times
but a lot of times people who are less
familiar with these topics can be a
little bit
confused like wait a minute isn't
diversity
maybe about lowering the bar and so the
answer is no
it's the opposite that that by designing
organizations to be more equitable and
raising the bar you
root out bias you root out in
group favoritism where i go out and i
find
you know people who look like me to join
my organization and i don't
i don't look at the full slate of
candidates because i've already said oh
i want my guy or i want my gal you know
it's actually through scrutinizing
carefully
design principles around equity that
organizations become more diverse and so
that's that's the particular
perspective i would say and it you know
every every
session it varies a bit um but that's
that's one of the
core themes awesome
thank you for sharing that i'm curious
uh from both of you if you have a
favorite
teaching moment i think you you kind of
alluded to
everyone coming into this kind of in
their own space but that
maybe there's a greater inclination or
affinity for this type
of content or subject material if people
are already opting in
um i i guess i would say if you could
pick
like your a favorite teaching moment for
someone maybe at different ends of the
spectrum if that's happened or if it
hasn't happened
it could be just interesting to share
well i do think about this last night
and i thought
i i love all my teaching moments like
how could i possibly pick one
but the one that always pops in my head
um is you know i i
you know you can't be what you can't see
it's a it's a big thing that drives
my the in particular the clash i teach
now and in the
in the winter right and um i'll never
forget
christina gilbeaux just and she wouldn't
mind my sharing the story
um just this fabulous woman who was in
my class who was black from atlanta
and she signed up to the class and she
came to the class first day and she said
i'm a non-entrepreneur i this is
i just thought i i'm at stanford i
should take the class and
see what it's like right like i'm not
gonna but i'm not gonna be an
entrepreneur
i need to let you know that is it okay
if i take the class and i'm like
yes this class is made for you come
you do not i do not judge
like success when someone like starts
the next facebook or i like that is not
what i'm about
and christina started an organization
called hope bound that
is just growing by leaps and bounds it
is
it is a non-profit it's helping
in middle school and high school get the
mental health they need
um it also helps those that are studying
to be mental health practitioners
get time with actual people who need
their help
it is it is the most incredible
organization
she is a born leader and
um and she also embraces all of the
concepts that we teach in equity by
design and it just
it it just is the perfect example of
of what what i love about the classes
that we teach
um so relatedly
i should i should mention that fern
teaches in the
the fall and winter quarters and
one of the things that's so wonderful
that i've noticed now
for a number of years is that the best
students
to fantastic students will take
fern's classes in the fall and winter
and because they like her so much
they'll take take these classes in the
spring too
and so by the time she and i teach in
the spring
i just i'm constantly in awe of our
of our class and so christina is so just
one of many students that's just been um
just an amazing person to know and and
i've counted it as a privilege to um
to report her um in equity by design
i'll i'll quickly add that
one of my favorite teaching moments
didn't
happen in the classroom it happened
after the first year of teaching
equity by design and
i i'm she's probably fine with me saying
her name but i won't give her last name
just in case but
there was a student annie who i i'd also
taught
um previously that
said to me after the class was over
that you know what was important about
the class
was that at her prior company
before coming to the to the gsb they had
always
wanted to do something around diversity
equity and inclusion
but they were afraid of doing the wrong
thing
and what the class did was help
um them understand her
understand what to do not that
it's prescriptive and you know it's not
the eight steps
that you take in every single situation
but it but it
through this better practices playbook
give gave her enough
um and and then relatedly
i learned so much that first quarter i
taught equity by design from students
in their final presentations and so
annie i still remember
um talked very personally about her
sister
who had um some learning challenges
and and what um non-neurotypical
people experience in the workforce and
it was
from that first class that
we revamped equity by design and burns
right we
we will constantly turn over the class
and make sure that we're pulling
um on new material and that it's
relevant
but that that first iteration
um we really focused on
after teaching together having as many
vectors
of diversity represented throughout the
class as possible
um and so we don't just focus on gender
we don't just focus on race we focus on
so
um able-bodiedness we focus on social
class
we i mean it just really um lgbtq um
gender identity aspects and that i think
has added a lot to
of depth to the class in ways that has
just been
um for me a pleasure to teach
yeah i think that was personally
incredibly impactful i
i remember um haven germa
who robin sorry i that's okay sorry for
mispronouncing the name but
just yeah i mean the invisibility of
some of the issues that continue to
exist and
and awareness is always being raised but
i think
you know it's it's amazing that even
those who are opting into a course like
this who might
have some aspects on their radar already
it's just the never-ending learning
and um i think do you mind if i tell
them quickly who hobbin is yeah please
that's so so just really quick so having
irma who we've
had in the class back-to-back years
which has been
great was the first um
deaf-blind student to graduate from
harvard law school
and um she's a woman of color she's an
immigrant and just one of the smartest
people
you would ever meet and and so um
we've had her come to class and she's
just
incredible but really all the speakers
we have are incredible and that's you
know
fern is masterful at tapping into her
widespread network and getting just
fantastic speakers um in the class
yeah including some really wonderful
alumni too i remember
um the ceo of blavity aaron
samuels and that was another one that
just stood out it's just really
wonderful to see people go full circle
from their jsv experience which is
amazing
um i think this is a great point in time
to pivot to some of the questions that
we might have from those who
are attending so i'm gonna pull up a few
um and feel free anyone who's online to
use the q a box
um i have a question we talked a little
bit about
just kind of um what happens with with
careers of students who take this course
but i have a question from someone who
currently works in management consulting
but is interested in pivoting into
dei focused work in the corporate world
and is there any advice that you've
given to those that are looking to
change a job function to be
more dei focused um
this person in particular said that
explaining their why is dei can
sometimes feel like a restrictive career
to break into so any advice
or guidance or things that you've seen
or learned from from your experience
i if you want to go into dei
now now is your time um there is such a
need
for dei people i i would say at
every company right now um so
if this is something that you're you're
truly passionate about
um i think there there really is is no
better time
to do this work
yeah i i agree and um
we we do spend some time on this in the
class
not necessarily now but for too long
dei work was sort of
the office work that didn't get
supported
or might not be comped um
and so if you're looking to move into a
dei role
i would have conversations about
how that's going to add value for the
company
and um
have those conversations so that your
contributions
get recognized um not that you can't
continue to do that work in tandem um if
you're already doing that work
but but really don't be afraid to say
this work is so important and guess what
i'm
i'm having lots of conversations about
this anyway
i'm doing what we will call culture work
and so you know i would love
to be recognized for that work in a way
that
shapes my specific role or function
that's great advice thank you
we have another comment from someone and
thank you for sharing i'm actually
seeing these in the chat box which is a
little different than q a so sorry i'm
not acknowledging you by name whoever
submitted this i i really appreciate
their candor
um just recognizing how mind-boggling
it's been the network of community that
they have
inherited as a result of the communities
they've been a part of
um and that network that they were able
to attain
um and they're wondering through your
research and work in the face of the
advantages that individuals can inherit
not by design but through an inherited
function like how do we make
more space for equity when you feel like
you've inherited that privilege
fern do you want you've been going
first i just wanted your
okay so so
thank you for the to the person that um
that asked this question and
one of the things that i think is
special about this question right now
is what i am
what i am seeing and um the
conversations i'm
having with people it's telling me that
all of us as we think about 2020
and and what we've been through um
[Music]
have varying levels of energy
right now and i i fernand and i were on
a
um call together a few weeks ago and i
shared this
after after george floyd was murdered
um one of the things that i
with my siblings really unpacked
was just how grateful we were
for allies that had energy
um that they were stepping up because
what we were noticing was that the black
community
was just really tired
after george and i'm not obviously i'm
not speaking for the entire black
community
we were just noticing among our friends
and family
this sense of exhaustion and so
when you feel like you have
stores of energy whether they're from
you know it's from a position of
privilege or um
you know just certain experiences that
you've had or your
your social position um
there is so much work to do and and so
one of the tricks
is i understand figuring out what to do
um i read a piece
that i put on my linkedin page after um
back in june when we were all sort of at
the height of
attending to social justice and race
racial inequity in this country um in
the summer
and what i encourage people to do is you
know
we know friend and i know that for most
of you you're not going to be dei
leaders
tomorrow i mean some maybe some of you
already are ti leaders but for the most
for the most part this is not going to
be your full-time job and so
and so what i like to encourage people
to do
is work at the margin um
you have continued to be in places and
spaces
where with an equity lens there will be
all sorts of ways um to use your social
capital your political capital
to speak up to speak out in ways that
enhance
the advanced dei and and so some of it
is just this willingness to kind of
continue to to see inequity and be
willing to speak up
um but then you can also if you're in
organizations with
dei leaders you can ask them you know
what can i do
i want to engage around this uh i'm sure
they would be thrilled
to have that question yeah
i'm i'm going to add one thing as well
here
um we we all have some level of
privilege
you know what i what i like to tell
people is that
we can all help others and the word we
use a lot
is is to be an ally um and
adina and i now take it a step further
and talk about what it means to be an
accomplice
and i i frankly love that word um
the definition i use for it is where my
success is tied to
someone else's success so it's not just
a
quick intro or oh maybe think about
doing that but like
really weighing in really trying to
really trying to help um and
and i believe if we all do that for one
or two people
i'm not saying you need to change the
whole organization
like literally one or two people if we
all did that
imagine the change we would see and so
that that is something we all can do
for someone else
beautiful thank you so i'm going to read
this next question
exactly how it was submitted i think
there is a lot to unpack in this
um so this person writes i think
professor sterling has already covered
some but i would like to further learn
your thoughts on giving advantages to
minority groups
versus equity do you think these two
conflict
and how to keep the balance
so there is a lot to unpack there
um so
here is the thing
i i think there's a lot to unpack in the
word
advantages um
if we if we take
even just the snapshot of 2020
and the
the racial inequities
that have been laid bare
through covid through various climate
impacts etc
it is it is hard to see
how systemic inequities
can be addressed outside of
very intentional interventions
and and the reason is that um
it's in you know we don't necessarily
get into
this that much in the class and so i
will say with this answer i'm speaking
um i'm giving my opinions and thoughts
and this is these are not
i don't want to sort of imply that
this is exactly what fern thinks or it's
kind of what we spend a lot of time
unpacking in the class
but but i believe that
you do have to focus on
systemic disadvantages and remediating
those
and in the background
in our lives in society there are
hidden advantages that people have
based on their social class based on
their race based on their gender
gender identity etc and so
it's not about giving necessarily
advantages
to people but it is about
very much so looking at sources of
disparity and saying
yeah we need targeted solutions
um and and to just sort of say
one policy is going to lift all boats
without
focusing in on specific interventions i
just don't think
that that's going to get us to where to
where we need to be
um i'll give one small example
really quickly that doesn't have to do
um
with race necessarily but there's a
wonderful
um woman who graduated from the phd
program in sociology
at stanford and she did a study her
dissertation her name is sharon jenk she
did a dissertation on
on gap jumpers which is this
organization that
works on creating work sample tests
so that in blinded ways blind to race
gender etc
you can have um
scores that software engineers
have have had when they complete coding
exercises
right and so the idea is that it no
longer matters if you're from stanford
or santa clara university
you get a fair shot and and so there's
no
intentional intervention there the
organizations that gap jumpers works
with
is happy they're happy to get these
student scores okay or sorry these um
these applicants scores but here's where
the problem
sets in it's not in it's not in the
scores
that um that these applicants get
on these coding exams um that's the
problem the problem is
when they sit across from hiring
managers
and they're from the santa clara
universities of the world
all of these biases come
into play that affect these the social
interactions that
happen in the context of these
interviews
such that if there aren't specific
interventions
where where you're saying look hiring
manager
you expect based on
maybe your cultural capital or training
that someone walks in they take it you
know
they immediately take command of the
room
and you all talk about you know
where you went to college and what you
have in common but
those processes disadvantage
people from certain backgrounds
and and so i do think
targeted interventions and not just
um what i will call race blind gender
bind
social class by blind interventions
i think do matter and are important
that was the long answer sorry
this is a really important topic i'm
going to give an example
i um head up early stage investing at
emerson collective um
the the venture capital industry you you
have to be hiding under a rock to know
that
very little capital goes to women um
and really any people of color in
particular you can imagine black
women um is like the lowest percentage
um when i arrived at emerson we started
we instituted
the using a rubric this is something we
talk a ton about
in our class right prior to making
decisions
how are you going to make the decision
and
the venture capital industry is fairly
known for
using pattern recognition my intuition
now i'm not saying that that's not
important and that it shouldn't be part
of the rubric
but you have to decide is 90
about the the total addressable market
or the team or
do they understand the customer and so
we now clearly go through that
and out of our 20 investments we've made
this year
17 are in founders from what what we
refer to as hugs
historically underestimated or
underrepresented groups
and 11 of those are people of color
and eight are actually black i had
two of the amazing black women speak in
my class this quarter
one today a woman named erica who
started a company called
ed lift i am not doing anything special
for erica she raised an incredible round
from
in a just the most the best
investors um but what we had to do was
exactly what adina said
is like not just fall back on the
processes we've used in the past which
is
does erica look like our other you know
investments did she
you know go to this particular school
study this particular thing
um look like the other people on our
website
right that's that is what we do we we do
it all the time
and so it is it's interrupting that
and for us it's having this rubric and
quite frankly after we have a
conversation
we literally say to each other now it's
taken about a year
but we'll say like did bias come into
that decision like
how did we make that decision how well
how did we do that
so much so that it you can imagine it's
almost not not a joke
funny haha like that doesn't matter but
just like
oh yeah i did i did and even bias like
i'm so hungry i just like can we just
move on
and that's a type of bias right like you
know you
you make that rash decision and you
didn't give it time
and we'll say like hey why don't we just
move this to tomorrow so
these interrupters it and
and i feel so strongly about this this
is not special treatment this is
actually the treatment
that we often give to these groups that
have just
gotten it that we don't even realize
frankly the special treatment they're
getting so
in no way are we giving special
treatment or focus or it's
it's it's just trying to really level
the playing field
that is really what we're trying to do
through through our rubric
thank you both didn't you didn't you say
and
hopefully it's okay that i say this if
not you can
text me afterwards uh i apologize but
but didn't you say that your portfolio
is outperforming just
all sorts of portfolio i mean the
approach that you're taking
um while your your portfolio of
companies
include founders that are diverse
on multiple vectors it's also
outperforming
um lots of other species
you know i came to emerson i was one of
the first investors in guild education
a white woman who is actually a graduate
of the business school
total totally amazing woman
rachel carlson eddie medina is the
co-founder of better up i was the first
investor in that company
i think they recently have a billion
dollar evaluation
um you know i'm an investor in blavity
which
everyone wants to be a part of i mean
these are
these are black white women
latina latino i'm starting these
amazing companies and i i just we
why i do why i joined a venture fund why
i'm committed to this is that
i don't actually think until we show the
world
how how amazing these founders are
um that will will actually believe it
and so
i i'm just delighted that they're
uh outperforming
that's so great thank you both so much
for putting words to a question that i
think is in the subtext of a lot of the
discourse that we're having now and not
all of us have the language to be able
to really um
have that complete dialogue so just want
to thank you so much for putting
all of those words and examples into
your answer to help all of us and equip
all of us to have that conversation
so i think we have time for about two
more questions and i'm going to ask
one um which actually comes from matia
from
italy and as many of you know
if you're on the call right now the gsb
is typically around 40
international students so this is a
great question asking
first of all congrats on the course
equity by design it seems really amazing
one question how do you think future
leaders
can bring such values in countries that
are just now experiencing a transition
to multiculturality
or otherwise thinking about dei from an
international perspective if that's
something you have a take on
i mean we um
some of our best presentations i will
see a fur decrease
but some of the best presentations
that we have have had from students at
the end of
the quarter the compressed class have
been
about this very topic that is
um students have taken these
these tools and these frameworks and
ideas and strategies
and they have designed
implementation processes and programs
for their native countries and
it's just you know i still remember one
presentation
um there were three members
and and they each did in 10 minutes
a 10-minute presentation they're their
home countries so we had
you know dei applied to i think it was
um
argentina israel and um
gosh maybe it was taiwan i might be
forgetting the third
but but this these
these frameworks are general enough to
travel
um and so you know
having a conversation about
multiculturalism
the us has had this conversation for a
long time
um
progress does not reflect the rhetoric
and so even though you might be
sitting in a country where you think
that the the multicultural narrative
isn't as advanced as it might be in
other places
that's okay because narratives only take
you so far anyway
is what i would say i also have to
say that that that this is every quarter
this happens
and almost invariably it's three men
that do this presentation which is
always
like we love men i mean we love
women we couldn't be more nonsense or
binary we like people but just
but we're still women the idea that
people
want to bring these concepts you know we
we love having international students in
our
in our classes and of course we're you
know
it makes the class that much richer
thank you for that and i'm gonna close
with a question
that i think really digs in to kind of
the meat and potatoes of your coursework
so um we have kind of themes around some
questions
um from a few different folks talking
about either being
in a level of the organization where
they find it difficult to advocate or
being in a company
where executive leadership or other
leadership isn't necessarily
bought in to the assumption that
diversity is beneficial for companies
and i know you spend a lot of time on
this
in the course and the question is what
existing research
can we point to that supports the need
for dei
um um
so it is a great question and we do
spend time on this in fact we role play
um foreign well i'll speak for myself
i'm not i'm not a great
actor but we we do role play uh this
very topic
because it's so important um
there is research on this uh
there's there's research that
indicates within teams that diverse
teams um come up with more creative
ideas that they're more innovative
um that they're less likely to
develop group think or siloing
ways of thinking that cut off ideas
there is research about
diversity on corporate boards and and
how
diversity leads to better governance
of of organizations um
but i'll just say what i find is
it's not often those more intellectual
kinds of studies that move the needle
you know for leaders oftentimes
it it's conversations and what can
sometimes
hold people back from a focus on dei
is that whether it's you know their
networks haven't provided
the opportunities or you know whatever
it might be
it's that they haven't heard personal
stories from people about their
experiences
um fern has a contact and
he's in my network too but just either
he's at is it ebay fern
damien cooper you know he likes to say
get proximate
um that proximity and sharing stories
moves the needle
on dei you know more than i think any
data
more than any particular study or set of
studies
and so for the person that's thinking
you know
what is it that is going to sway the ceo
of my company or
you know the leader of my team
i think it's going to be personal
stories
around why you think this matters and
and
and your background and your perspective
um more so than any than any research
but
if you do you can google catherine
phillips if you want to name katherine
phillips has this wonderful um
piece and did a lot of ground breaking
work on diverse city and teams
um was formerly at columbia sadly passed
away this year
um this past january but that's that's
one name i
i would recommend um and
we're happy to get you some more scott
page if
you know he writes a lot about diversity
has a couple books
but but you can find those studies they
they exist
yeah the only thing i would add to this
is
you know we talk a lot about how to um
create an inclusive environment where
people feel like they belong and i
i know that we people usually say that
and i'm not sure they always know
what they mean by that um but if you
if you really feel like you're
part of the team right you tend to work
harder
you care more you you're more engaged
you're more productive
um that is just better for business
and i can point to um jeff weiner
or the ceo of surveymonkey like they
will just talk about this that it's just
everyone is is also happier but that
that
that isn't you know i'm not suggesting
you talk about happiness although
we care greatly about that but they're
more engaged they're more productive
they're more creative they're more
innovative
there's tons of data that supports us
when people feel that way
and that everyone can reach their full
potential
they then bring in more people company
the companies you're talking about are
probably growth companies right now
they have to hire people if you're
hiring one color and one gender
you kind of have a limited pool of
applicants
it probably doesn't reflect the
customers right
and so we do talk about these things in
our class like
why it is good for business for sure
but what adina is saying i've worked
with companies all around the world as
hesadina
that's not what causes them to to move
the needle
when i share how someone on their team
feels or
when they had the opportunity to re to
really contribute in a meeting
it changed their whole perspective it
they just wanted
they just wanted to work harder and when
they hear that
and see it wow it is
it i mean it's an amazing thing and it's
great for
it's great for business
those are great words of wisdom to close
on
i want to thank you both so much for
taking the time
to do this i think um it's a big
testament to the ways in which
you're advancing this work in and of
itself so
thank you so much for your time and your
inspiration
and i hope those of you that joined us
today
will at some point have a class that
have a chance to take this course
um and if not stay engaged with us
throughout the rest of the week to learn
more about what the gsv is doing in this
arena
so thank you so much